oh so basically the goal of today I
don't even know how to pronounce it
Fleur would you pronounce it for clear
Fleur Fleur this is the take Sasquatch
running - it is fairly new level but no
one understands you can't find swap out
a thermal camera nope
this is picking up
my god
you can see in complete darkness so
you're basically just take a picture or
to take a video or change the hell
so palette happens to be outdoors people
like red target on any kind of Hannibal
gets it out of the clutter
the classic military one is in white
oxygen 2000
and then you
ninety eighty nine point eight
I'm gonna put this shutter down hold it
till you get a check part
93 92 you're good general my temperature
I'm so there you know
we're gonna find sasquatch
we're talking
and a takeaway is not only is this
amazing but who learns how to pronounce
the company it's clear clear clear clear
dear dear clear dear clear